[Musique]
en soufflant à plus de 350 km à l'heure
des vagues déchaînées déferlant sur les
habitations c'est le 18e qui font que
l'archipel japonais et essuyer cette
année 650 mille personnes ont fui à
souffrir de ces violences
le bilan compte parmi les plus
désastreux qu'on est enregistrée 175
morts 20 disparus 3000 blessés et 74
mille habitations écrasé ou emportées
par les flots en furie
[Applaudissements]
en
va-t-on revoir s'enflammer en belgique
le vieil antagonisme entre wallons et
flamands
63000 flamands ont défilé dans les rues
de la capitale belge aux cris de
bruxelles flamand slogan auquel les
fédéralistes wallon répondu par d'autres
slogans bousculent à des bagarres ont
finalement émaillé cette manifestation
qui avait débuté dans l'indifférence des
bruxellois et dont le but était double
dans l'esprit de ses protagonistes
affirmer les droits des flamands sur
bruxelles et réclamer la fixation
définitive de la frontière linguistique
entre wallons et flamands
et
quatre blessés en définitive et 10
arrestations
mais bruxelles à la fière
m
[Musique]
plusieurs nuits durant les forces de
police sont restées en état d' alerte à
paris à la suite des manifestations
auxquelles avaient pris par vingt mille
musulmans algériens à ménilmontant comme
à la goutte d'or le rideau de fer
étaient tirés devant les boutiques et
les cinémas
journée de manifestations silencieuses
la grève des commerçants algériens assez
généralement suivies
[Musique]
en dépit du dispositif de surveillance
de la police les musulmans algériens
n'avaient pas renoncé à continuer leurs
manifestations mais cette fois ce furent
des groupes de femmes et d'enfants qui
tentèrent de se former groupe qui devait
être rapidement canaliser vers les
centres sociaux de la préfecture de la
seine en tout un millier de femmes
peuvent ainsi appréhender pour être
reconduite chez elle
tous les manifestants arrêtaient le
premier soit il y en eut 11500 ne devait
pas connaître le même sort 15 cents en
effet ont été refoulés vers l'algérie
dans leurs douars d'origine c'est ainsi
qu'à orly cent quarante quatre d'entre
eux ont été embarqués à destination de
constantine
[Musique]
mais
à tunis où il a été l'hôte du président
bourguiba le président de la république
du sénégal monsieur léopold sédar
senghor a sans doute beaucoup parler de
l'algérie il a eu notamment au cours de
son séjour avec les responsables du fln
des entretiens qu'il a qualifié de
fructueux
et continuant son voyage par paris il
est allé à l'elysée conquis au général
de gaulle ses impressions sur la
nouvelle équipe du gpr à qu'ils
déclaraient avoir trouvé assez positive
est disposé à négocier toutefois le
président senghor s'est nettement
défendu de vouloir assurer les bons
offices entre la france et le fln
[Musique]
moscou dans la nouvelle salle du kremlin
monsieur khrouchtchev a ouvert le 22ème
congrès du parti communiste soviétique
il l'a ouvert par un premier discours de
six heures juste derrière lui le
maréchal vorochilov ci est entendue
désigné comme l'un des instigateurs du
complot anti parts l'albanie quant à
elle a subi également les foudres de
monsieur k qu'il l'a accusé de
déviationnisme ce que la chine en
monsieur chen là il n'a ni apprécié ni
applaudi parmi les autres chapitres
recherche avec l'ouest d'une solution
concrète et annonce d'une explosion
nucléaire de 50 mégatonnes
[Musique]
la vie moderne que de simplification ne
lui dois tombe pas c'est par exemple
cette sphère de 9 grammes qui va
remplacer les lots chariots des machines
à écrire et permettre le changement
instantanée des caractères
[Musique]
c'est aussi l'ingénieux système qui
permettra aux automobilistes qu'ils
trouveront leur route et gonflé de
sortir de leur ennui branché l'autre
extrémité du tuyau à la valve d'une roue
normalement gonflés et attendre
calmement que les changes gaz se soit
fait simple direz vous encore fallait-il
y pense
à
l'art de ses ventes et à la mode
orientale a fait lui aussi de sérieux
progrès depuis qu'on a adopté la
technique du batteur de carpète à moteur
enfin d'amérique nous bien l'image donc
tous les hommes ont rêvé depuis ici car
l'homme volant du moins le solde à
volants puisque c'est l'armée américaine
qui a expérimenté la nouvelle ceinture
fusée avec succès comme on voit
[Musique]
poésie pas mort tu disais un télégramme
célèbres tel pourrait être aussi la
justification de cette exposition
consacrée aux activités de quelques
personnages particulièrement inspiré de
monsieur marc mains des essarts en
vendée par exemple qui ne se contente
pas d'être simplement le jardinier
horticulteurs qu'il est né transforme à
coups de sécateurs son jardin en un
univers avicole qui ne manque pas de
féerie
dans sa villa au bord de la nationale 7
près dé san monsieur cérons lui autre
inspiré manille le fil de fer et le
ciment ainsi perfectionne t-il d'année
en année un autre univers singulier
d'animaux et de personnages chez qui la
légende le dispute à l'histoire perd la
victoire compris avis à la postérité cet
artiste modeste prend soin d'enfermer
dans chacune de ses oeuvres sa carte de
visite et le journal du jour
[Musique]
mais le plus inspiré et certainement
monsieur isidore gardien de cimetière
près de sharp qui a réussi à faire
disparaître sa maison sous l' enveloppe
de son oeuvre de céramistes avec un
talent consommé monsieur isidore manil
assiettes cassées
[Musique]
rien ne lui a échappé et pas seulement
les murs et des planchers tout le
mobilier a subi les effets de son amour
de l'art pour lequel depuis 30 ans ils
sacrifient allègrement la vaisselle du
ménage mais la noblesse d'une cause ne
justifie t'elle pas les plus grands
sacrifices
[Musique]
les footballeurs du racing club de paris
maillot claire sont à l'image des
joueurs de l'équipe de france ils n'ont
pas bien digéré la technique du football
moderne le football est un jeu simple
les joueurs de nîmes leur en administre
la fois
le droit au but c'est la devise des
nîmois qui donne une leçon parfois
gênantes au parisien qui frise le
ridicule devant trente mille spectateurs
pas toujours très fiers de leur équipe
roger marche est sans doute le seul
joueur du racing a tenté quelque chose
au moins lui il ne s'embarrasse pas de
fioritures ce qui n'empêche pas des
nîmois de continuer leur petite
exhibition bien simple est bien nette et
sans bavure on apprécie en connaisseur
dans les tribunes et pendant ce temps
sur le terrain les nîmois ne s'arrête
pas en si bon chemin ils sont sans pitié
pour le racing les bus ajoute au but 3 0
et ce n'est pas fini jugez en par les
réactions des spectateurs
4 à 0 pour terminer et c'est encore bon
marché du béton à la sortie du parc des
princes
en
soi c'est la devise de ces pilotes
allemands se faire respecter sur la
route il faut regarder les choses en
face et surtout garder son sang froid
avec ce système le problème du
croisement est facile à résoudre
ici la méthode n'est pas encore tout à
fait tout on peut être encore mieux en
définitive respecter le code de la route
c'est même plus sûres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]